Well, please welcome back to the show.
I still wanna call you a drew crew.
It's Aliza Kelly
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much.
I mean, I love it here.
We are the OG, baby.
Yeah, we go back.
We're thrilled because
you're gonna bring your cosmic talents
right there to People TV.
I'm so excited for you, Aliza.
Tell me about it.
Thank you so much.
I am so excited too.
So my love, like, in my mind,
astrology and pop culture sit right next to each other.
I love them both.
So this show is the fusion of that.
We are going to be looking at celebrity charts.
So we're looking at people like Mike King, Harry styles,
Aquarius king, Megan Fox, Machine Gun Kelly.
We need to know what's going on there.
So we look at that.
You actually gonna do my chart too,
and we're gonna put it on the websites so you can see that.
Oo.
Yas. But since you're here and you're reading
charts with the stars,
can we get your cosmic take on some pop culture stories?
Yes, of course.
Let's hit it.
First up, People reports HBO Max
just released a new two-part documentary
all about Brittany Murphy.
Take a look at this.
Women in Hollywood are pressured enormously.
She had lost an enormous amount of weight,
and she was dressing totally differently.
She said, that's what I've been told.
If I wanted to be considered as a leading lady.
During a little dip she was having, he came along,
and I think that's where her judgment was muddled.
And she became prey.
Yeah, this is a very complicated story
everyone's talking about it.
It was just on the cover of People magazine-
That's right.
Yeah, and there's still so much mystery surrounding this.
Now, when you look at her chart,
is there anything helpful in there?
Brittany's chart is very riveting.
It's really interesting because
she was born during a new moon in Scorpio.
So that means that the sun,
which represents your identity,
how you aluminate,
how you take up space.
And then also the moon,
your emotional inner world is in the sign
that is associated with intensity and passion,
and also secrets.
So I am not surprised that all of these years later,
we are still trying to figure out what happened
because that is really baked into her birth chart.
I am curious about this documentary.
I worked with Brittany, actually.
We did a film together called "Riding in Cars With Boys,"
and we got very close.
She was a force.
She was a good friend.
She was very empathic,
extremely sensitive,
almost as if she didn't have skin.
She could read a room and start crying in a moment's notice,
you know, whether it was for work
or because she was sort of taking on
someone else's emotions.
She was a very good, kind person.
And it seems like she just got caught up in something.
And that was really when we lost touch.
So I'm eager to see it because the mystery is haunting to us
to see this beautiful, bright star, dim the lights.
[Aliza] Yeah.
Well said, and there's still so many unanswered questions.
So, I'll be tuning in for sure.
Yeah, me too.
All right, well next step,
Meghan and Harry, People reports that
they've just taken a partnership on with Ethic,
a financial firm that helps people invest in companies
that do good.
Now, this is important because we've got to get it together
on this planet so we can remain here.
This couple, why do they seem so United on all fronts?
What is the astrological reasoning here?
Megan and Harry are karmically, cosmically.
Every single way you could be connected, these two are.
But really this relationship
is built on healing,
all of the signatures for healing, and for transformation,
and for change,
and growth show up in the chart.
And we're gonna see that
in every venture they take on together,
because everything that they wanna do,
they wanna do it from really heart-led.
As someone who grew up idolizing princess Diana,
I got to meet her when I was seven years old,
and she was so important and meaningful to us.
She showed people that people with aids at that point
were allowed to be touched.
She fought for landmines.
She changed the world,
and to see Harry in a healing place
after what's happened and she was taken away from us,
it is healing.
I'm glad that there is goodness there continuing on.
I Have goosebumps.
Me too, I...
(audience claps)
I'm so fascinated by them.
I'm so glad they're doing such good with their lives,
but I still don't understand
how they could have left the Royal family.
I'm sorry, but my entire life I've had that dream
that one day the phone would ring and I'd be like,
"I'm princess of Genova, I am."
(Drew and Aliza laugh)
(audience laughs)
You know, I mean that's my fantasy.
So the fact they left is so fascinating.
But it's in their charts
that this is their mission in life, right?
So I have to tell you about their charts.
Meghan introduces Harry to things
that he would not have access to otherwise.
Really?
She exposes insight
about his family,
about the world that he came from,
about his mother, that without her influence
he wouldn't have been able to see.
So it's really, very profound.
Fascinating.
Well, I think your show
is gonna be huge, Aliza Kelly.
"Celebrity Astrology
(Audience claps)
Investigation"
is available on Free Streamer, People TV
with new episodes every Tuesday.
(upbeat music)